you
she's back at Stanford but not back to
real work or school just yet helping us
to break down the critical moments from
these World Chess Championship games is
of course woman's Vidya Master Alexander
beau tez again and Alexandra on that
note this critical moment move 18 from
today's game had everybody wondering
what's going to happen with the pawns
how are they going to be traded how are
the players going to handle this tension
and I'm going to turn it over to you and
let you tell everybody what they can
learn from what Magnus Carlsen did here
so this game is very instructive for
beginner and intermediate players
because usually first instinct is to try
to alleviate the tension and go for the
trades as soon as you see them so in
this position he takes f5 or C takes D 3
but instead Magnus taught us that he can
continue to keep the tension and try to
fight for a win even in a position that
looks Josh he continued by playing C 3
after B take C 3 he surprised us again
by not taking back right away
instead he played the bold move d5 so
trying to build more tension on the
board trying to play exciting chess
after Bishop g5 it was kind of clear
that it would be very difficult to push
a win here nevertheless as the game went
on he was able to get a passed pawn on
the e-file so he was able to get plenty
of compensation for his otherwise
sacrificed pawn unfortunately he wasn't
able to win this time but it was still
instructive on how we can continue to
create tension in an otherwise drush
looking game yeah great breakdown and I
think it is very hard especially for
inexperienced players to look at a trade
in the face and not blink and just let
it build but let's go back to this
moment cuz as you said without this
building on the tension creating even
more of it the possible tactics that
occurred in this game would have never
happened
the key point everybody is that C takes
d4 was not possible because this check
is now a fork and even taking on d5
would be ill-advised because now black
could take f5 and either white would
have to retreat probably losing all
these pawns in the process or fail prey
to another tactical possibility where
black can clear the smoke and just like
that there's a double attack of the
bishop hanging and the move Bishop to d4
check coming so as you said he was not
able to win
but it does show that building on
tension creating those opportunities for
your opponent to go wrong is the first
step toward winning a lot of these games
and something strong players do all the
time that we can learn from Thank You
Alexandra you will not be with us for
the final game you'll be back to work
there at Stanford but everybody make
sure you're with us for the critical
moment break down after game 12
you